Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul. Today.
We're going to look at the Wolf language.
Some of you have probably never even heard of Wolf before,
but it's an important language of West Africa.
And you might even know a little bit of Wolf already.
Wolf was one of the languages spoken among African slaves,
brought to the Americas.
And a number of words that are off possible will of origin have entered American
English via African-American vernacular English.
Most of them were introduced into the mix main stream through the popularity of
jazz music.
They include jive dig juke as in jukebox and hip.
These words may seem a bit out of date now,
but they were very important words in American culture. In the 20th century,
the word banana may also be of well of origin though.
It entered English via Spanish or Portuguese Wolf is spoken by at least 6
million native speakers.
The vast majority of them in Senegal were around 40% of the population speaks it
as a native language,
but Wolf is also used as a lingua franca throughout much of Senegal.
So including second language speakers around 80% of the population can speak it.
And I've seen estimates as high as 90%.
The official language of Senegal is French, not Wolf, but will,
if is the most widely spoken language it's also spoken by around 20% of the
people in Gambia,
including more than half of the people in the capital city than Juul,
as well as around 7% of the people of Mauritania.
It's a member of the Senegambia in branch of the Nigeria Congo language family,
which is also known as the Northern Atlantic branch.
The name Wolf means people of loaf,
an area in present day Senegal where the jollof empire also known as the Wolf
empire was established at the end of the 14th century.
It's the name of the Wolf ethnic group as well as their language,
because most wall of people converted to Islam in recent centuries.
And because of the presence of Arab traders in the region will have some Arabic
influence. Some Arabic lone words include
the traditional Islamic greeting. Some of the days of the week,
Tuesday from Arabic,
[inaudible] Wednesday from Arabic
Thursday, from Arabic Al homies and, uh,
Juma Friday from Arabic Algoma last
time or hour,
this is from Arabic walked or walk to which includes the Arabic nominative
case ending. Ooh, there are some more words, but not that many, to be honest,
there has also been French influence on Wolf that's because Senegal is a former
French colony,
the French established trading outposts there beginning in the 17th century and
fully conquered Senegal. During the 19th century,
it remained a French colonial territory until 1960. The duck,
our variety of Wolf has the most French influence with numerous French lone
words. The rural varieties of Wolf are more conservative.
We'll see some examples of French loan later. Some features of Wolfe,
the semi Gumby and languages, including Wallace do not have tones.
This sets them apart from most of the Nigeria Congo language family,
like other languages in its family. Well, if contains pre nasalized continence,
these are combinations of nasal sounds and stops,
which function as individual continents like most Niger Congo languages
Wolf has a system of known classes,
categories of different types of nouns that are represented by specific
inflections. But Willow is unique in that the noun itself is not inflicted,
but rather it's typically the definite article that is inflected. For example,
the shirt and miss V the cat moves me,
the woman [inaudible] the earth [inaudible] now in class
inflection can be seen in the first consonant of the definite article.
There are 10 mountain classes, including two plural classes though,
understand that an urban Wolf B has replaced the others to a large extent.
Wolf has no separate grammatical category of adjectives.
Instead there's a category of verbs called state of verbs,
which indicates States, conditions, feelings, et cetera.
These are used in set of adjectives.
Wolf has three sets of personal pronouns, independent pronouns, object,
pronouns, and subject pronouns. Independent pronouns are used for emphasis.
And to answer questions similar to the disjunctive pronouns in French,
independent pronouns and object pronouns have fixed forms,
but subject pronouns have many different forms in the Wolf verb system.
The verb itself is not conjugated, but rather the subject pronoun is inflected.
Instead the subject pronouns indicate not only person and number,
but can also indicate time, normally aspect rather than tents,
as well as focus. It can be verbal focus, object, focus, or subject focus.
There are three types of verbs in Wolf action, verbs, identity, verbs,
and state of verbs, which we mentioned before.
Identity verbs are verbs that give basic information about you and your
background such as dude, to be named yoga,
to come from you do to be born. And so on.
These three types of verbs are important because they're used in different
verbal constructions, different conjugations, if you will.
All right,
let's jump right into some sentences and see some of these features in action.
This sentence means what's your name,
word for word it's how you singular named [inaudible] is an
object focused pronoun.
It's focusing our attention on the word NUCCA meaning how so it's often used in
asking or answering questions that identify the object or compliment this.
Here is the second person, singular object focused pronoun, to be clear.
There's a full set of these object focused pronouns for the various persons and
numbers. These are subject pronouns,
but they have the added function of telling us to focus on or emphasize the
object. This is one set of subject pronouns with that specific function,
but there are numerous other sets of subject pronouns with different functions.
Here too.
Is the identity verb,
meaning to be from note that this question is often contracted.
To know to do with not.
Being a contraction of NACA and God,
but I give you the full form to show how the underlying sentence.
And says constructed an answer might be good to do.
Word for word it's Gorda. That's a name I named in this reply.
LA is the first person singular object focused pronoun.
One thing to note is that Wolf typically follows an SVO word order,
but in an object focused sentence with a verb it's O S V to give a greater sense
of the object focus. Maybe in English, we could translate this as it is Gora.
I am called here's another sentence with object focus, similarly,
gala. This means.
I love my job, or it is my job that I love.
Maybe you'd say this in response to a question,
asking what you love about your life. Now let's make this a subject focus.
Sentence. My big somebody gay. This means.
I love my job with the emphasis on the subject. I maybe you'd say this.
If someone asks, who loves their job, overhearing your conversation.
Now let's make this a verb focus.
[Inaudible] this means.
I love my job with the emphasis on love.
Maybe you say this in response to someone asking if you dislike your job.
Notice again, that in the object focused sentence,
the object comes at the beginning.
Also remember that these are subject pronouns,
which include the additional meaning of focus.
These ones here are only the first person singular forms,
which are part of wider sets of pronouns.
This form here.
Indicates verbal focus for action verbs.
But when it's a state of verb that functions like an adjective,
then this form draws our attention to a state or can.
Does the tongue it's hot here.
Tongued is a state of verb. Meaning to be hot.
This construction is often used to explain a reason or cause let's look at
another sentence. This means they're having breakfast.
This sentence contains a different kind of pronoun called a preventative
pronoun. These pronouns don't have any focus,
but rather indicate an aspect of time.
They tell us that some action or condition is currently true.
This part here in geek,
on its own means here like the action or condition you can see right in front of
you with an action verb. This particle E is added to the end of the pronoun,
which makes it like the present continuous in English.
But with an identity verb,
it tells us something about someone's current identity.
Even if that part of the person's identity stems from an occurrence in the past.
Lyndon, Dick buddy, I live in Paris. Lindy.
I grew up in Dakar.
With identity verbs.
The E affix is missing from the pronoun because your identity is not a present
continuous action. It's your current state. It's who you are.
If you think about the way these presentive pronouns are used with verbs,
you can see that they don't indicate tents, but rather aspect.
They show that a condition is ongoing, even if it was caused by a past action.
Another sentence.
This.
Means we ate before you arrived word for word it eat.
We perfective before you arrive. This verb.
Liquor is an action verb. It's related to the word Leeka meaning food,
which derives from an Arabic word. As we saw before this pronoun,
Nunu is an enunciated pronoun or a perfective pronoun,
which shows completion of the action.
This is often used when the simple Pastore past perfect would be used in
English.
I should point out that while Wolf has generally SVO in perfective sentences,
the verb comes at the beginning. So this is VSO.
The pronoun [inaudible] is a neutral pronoun that contains no time or focus
element in a clause with latter meaning before there is no aspect or tents.
These neutral pronouns are also used a lot in speech.
In which case tents and aspect are understood from context.
One thing that might be confusing here is that in God is the same as the second
person, singular object focused pronoun, which we saw before.
I probably should have used a different one of the neutral pronouns in this
sentence to avoid that confusion.
When the perfective is used with a state of verb,
it doesn't indicate a past state. It indicates a present state.
The perfective indicates that the development of that state is completed.
Um, notice.
This sentence means I already have a reservation word for word it's have I
perfective reservation already,
not the French word [inaudible] here.
You can see that a present state is expressed by the perfective form. Now,
if we want to express a past state using a state of verb,
we can add a special past marker.
Um, I'm not [inaudible].
This means I already had a reservation rather than have a reservation.
Another sentence.
[Inaudible].
This means tomorrow we'll go to the market word for word it's tomorrow.
We imperfect go market. The in the sentence,
we see a different type of subject pronoun that indicates future well,
to be precise.
It's the imperfection and indicates that an action has not been completed yet.
Here we have the word for market, which comes from the French word, Marsha,
and it's followed by the definite article four. It's now in the class,
this one starting with a B the imperfection of pronouns do not always express
future. If we add to them the suffix E which expresses continuous action,
that the imperfection of pronouns indicate a habitual action,
which would be expressed with the simple present tense in English.
[Inaudible].
This means we go to the market every day here,
we see an imperfect of pronoun with the prefix E which makes this a habitual
action. Like we go rather than a future action.
Like we will go in the phrase based boot neck base means day
and brunette means each or every let's look at one last
sentence. [inaudible]
this means the children aren't sleeping.
They're chatting word for word it's children that sleep negative.
They continuous chat.
This sentence is about actions that are in progress right now.
So here we see the preventative pronoun [inaudible]
, which indicates ongoing action that they are chatting right now, closer to the beginning of the sentence. We have this verb
Nyla, which means sleep with a negative suffix, but no preventative
pronoun. This negative suffix indicates person and number third person, plural, but it doesn't contain any information about time or focus. It's simply negative.
This is the normal way of expressing the negative for all types of verb
constructions.
So the time and focus elements are understood from context here at the
beginning, we see the phrase, Holly, which means the children.
He is a definite article for plural nouns.
There's one more definite article for plural nouns ne but that one is quite
limited in use.
These plural articles are two of the 10 definite articles that are marked for
now in class. One less thing to note is the word wok tan.
The root of this word is wa which means to speak and the suffix ton
changes the meaning to chat. And it can also be unowned,
meaning conversation or chat,
but there are numerous other words built from this route.
There is meaning to have someone speak the causative form
side, which means to haggle or to bargain,
which means to repeat or restate and loss,
which means to talk to yourself. And there's also a homonym of this word,
meaning time or hour, which comes from the Arabic word walk to,
as you can see, Wolf is a very interesting language.
And one that might work quite differently from your native language or any other
language that you've studied before,
perhaps its standout feature is its verbal system,
which makes extensive use of inflected pronouns,
which work together with largely unchangeable verbs to create a rich system of
expression. In this video,
we merely scratched the surface and there are more constructions that indicate
different times aspects and moods.
And there are additional features of the language that are beyond the scope of
this video,
but hopefully it's sparked your interest and you learn something new.
The question of the day to native speakers of Wolf.
If there are any of you watching,
what differences do you notice between urban Wolf,
especially that of Ducker and rural Wolf?
Are they major differences and to anyone who has visited Senegal or another Wolf
speaking area, did you learn any Wolf? If so, what was your experience? If not,
were you able to get around using French or English if you enjoyed this video,
be sure to check out Lang focused on the various social media platforms like
Facebook, YouTube, Twitter, and Instagram. And as always,
I'd like to give a special thanks to my Patrion supporters,
especially my top two,
your Patriot and supporters who you see right here on the screen,
many special thanks to them and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day.
Okay.